hi I'm Greg Sadler I'm the host of dr.
sailors philosophy forum a monthly
google hangout on air which allows
viewers to weigh in with the
question-and-answer app this month I'm
going to be interviewing Robert skiff
the CEO of a player know a new education
company it's a for-profit entirely
online they just got accredited in the
state of Vermont and they're seeking
accreditation through a lot of other
agencies and they are really doing
something new unusual unprecedented in
higher education so it's going to be
very interesting conversation you got
two people myself and Robert skiff who
have a deep abiding interest in what's
going on in higher education in America
worldwide thinking about is college in
fact a good gamble for people about
student debt about the current status of
adjuncts all sorts of topics that we're
going to talk about that have been in
the news lately so you want to join us
for that or at least you know watch the
video afterwards if you want to join us
it's going to be May twenty-fourth
that's this saturday of memorial day
weekend and it will be at six pm eastern
standard time and run to about 7 30
maybe eight o'clock if if we get a lot
of questions and answers that we can't
get to depending on how long I can tear
Rob away from his his you know family
obligations since it is a holiday
weekend so I invite everybody to to
first of all weigh in I'm going to
enable the question-and-answer app once
this is this is uploaded and ask your
questions make your comments will
respond to them I invite you to view it
will be live streaming 6pm May
twenty-fourth or you can watch it
afterwards